GOING TO VOTE FOR DONALD TRUMP.
BILL: RIC GRENELL, THANK YOU.
THIS IS HOW MINNESOTA CAME OUT 4
YEARS AGO.
HILLARY CLINTON NARROW WIN, A
LOT OF PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT THIS,
JUST 44,000 VOTES IN 2016.
I MENTIONED MICHIGAN A MOMENT
AGO AND JUMP BACK HERE BECAUSE
THIS WAS THE STATE THAT WAS
DECIDED BY 11,000 VOTES.
TRUMP BEATING HILLARY CLINTON IN
WOLVERINE STATE.
DEBBI DINGELL, YOU CAME ON THE
AIR WITH ME IN 2016 AND SAID, I
THINK TRUMP CAN WIN THIS THING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK NOW?
CONGRESSWOMAN: HI, BILL, GOOD TO
SEE YOU, WE WILL KEEP GOING.
IT’S GOING TO BE GO BLUE DAY ON
TUESDAY.
I DON’T BELIEVE THE POLLS.
THE ONLY POLL THAT MATTERS IS
THE POLL ON ELECTION DAY.
PEOPLE HAVE TO GO VOTE AND THIS
IS COMING DOWN TO VOTER TURNOUT,
VOTER TURNOUT.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN’T
BELIEVE THAT DONALD TRUMP COULD
WIN, A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
MICHIGAN, 90,000 PEOPLE LEFT TOP
OF THE TICKET BLANK LAST TIME
AND YOU DON’T FEEL THAT.
BUT I DO FEEL IN CERTAIN PARTS
OF THE STATES WITH CERTAIN
DEMOGRAPHICKING --
DEMOGRAPHICKING IT IS
TIGHTENING.
THE REASON PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
JOE BIDEN IS YOU HAVE TO GET
PEOPLE OUT AND YOU CAN’T TAKE
THEM FOR GRANTED AND WOMEN ARE
TURNING OUT IN MASSIVE NUMBERS
MUCH MORE SO THAN THEY DID 4
YEARS AGO.
BILL: SOME OF THE ANECDOTAL
EVIDENCE ESPECIALLY IN FLORIDA,
HOW MUCH CONCERN DO YOU HAVE
ABOUT HISPANIC VOTES GOING FOR
TRUMP AND AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SUPPORT BEING SOFT?
CONGRESSWOMAN: LOOK, I DON’T
TAKE ANYTHING FOR GRANTED.
I’M NOT ONE OF THE CHEERLEADERS
THAT SAYS THIS IS A DONE
ELECTION.
IT’S NOT GOING TO BE DONE.
EVERY PERSON THAT HASN’T VOTED
THAT CARE STRONGLY NEED TO GO
OUT AND VOTE.
I THINK MOMENTUM IS WITH JOE
BIDEN RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE THAT COVID IS AN ISSUE
THAT PEOPLE ARE GOING TO VOTE ON
BUT I DO THINK THAT IT TURNED
PEOPLE’S WORLD UPSIDE DOWN.
TODAY IN MICHIGAN WE HAD THE
HIGHEST NUMBER YET.
IT’S SURGING IN STATE AS CROSS
THE COUNTRY AND PEOPLE ARE
SCARED.
THEY’RE SCARED ABOUT THEIR JOBS,
THEY’RE SCARED ABOUT WHAT’S
GOING TO HAPPEN TO IT.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAD CHOSEN TO
WEAR A MASK IN MANY PLACES,
BECAUSE PEOPLE LISTEN TO HIM,
BECAUSE PEOPLE FOLLOW HIM, HE
WOULD HAVE REDUCED THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND WOULD HAVE REDUCED
THE DEATHS.
IF HE COMES TO MICHIGAN -- YOU
HAVE TO GO?
BILL: IT’S OKAY.
I HAVE A MINUTE LEFT.
THE POINT YOU’RE DRIVING OUT
THERE AND WE WILL SEE ON
WEDNESDAY WHAT THE STATE OF
COVID IS ON -- ON BEHALF OF BOTH
MEN.
FINAL POINT HERE, THOUGH, WHAT
WE HEAR FROM REPUBLICANS
CONSISTENTLY IS THEY GO TO
BATTLEGROUND STATES AND THEY SEE
NO GROUND GAME FOR JOE BIDEN.
THOUSAND DO YOU -- HOW DO YOU
FEEL ABOUT THAT?
>> THERE’S BEEN GROUND GAME AND
MILLIONS OF CALLS.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
WILL MEASURE THAT AT SOME POINT.
I CAN TELL YOU I’VE HAD A GROUND
GAME, 49,000 PEOPLE THAT HAVE
RETURNED AB BALLOTS THAT DID NOT
VOTE IN 2016.
WE ARE DOING DOORS AND TARGETED
STATE LEGISLATIVE SEATS, HAVE
BEEN DOING DOORS SINCE JULY.
THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN HAS NOW
STARTED DOING CANVASS, WE DO
HAVE A GROUND GAME AND WE WILL
DELIVER ON TUESDAY.
BILL: DO YOU WANT TO GIVE US A
PREDICTION 3 DAYS OUT
CONGRESSWOMAN?
>> CAN I GIVE YOU A PREDICTION
ON MONDAY?
I DO THINK JOE BIDEN IS LIKELY
TO WIN BUT IT’S HIGHER THAN WHAT
PEOPLE THINK RIGHT NOW.
BILL: THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.